dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly life ahead we've seen
a lot of fluid and smoke simulations
throughout the series in each of these
cases the objective was to maximize the
realism of these animations often to the
point where they are indistinguishable
from reality however there are cases
where creating photorealistic footage is
not the main objectives artists often
seek to imbue these fluid and smoke
simulations with their own distinctive
style and this style needs not to be
photorealistic it can be cartoonish
black and white or take a variety of
different color schemes but
unfortunately to obtain such an effect
we have to sit down get a bunch of
papers and draw the entirety of the
animation frame by frame and of course
to accomplish this we also need to be
physicists and know the underlying laws
of fluid dynamics that's not only
borderline impossible but extremely
laborious as well it would be really
cool to have an algorithm that is
somehow able to learn our art style and
apply it to a fluid or smoke simulation
sequence but the question is how do we
exactly specify this style have a look
at this really cool technique I love the
idea behind it first we compute a
classical smoke simulation then we
freeze a few frames and get the artists
to colorize them after that the
algorithm tries to propagate this
artistic style to the entirety of the
sequence intuitively this is artistic
style transfer for fluid animations but
without using any machine learning
techniques here we are doing patch based
regenerative morphing this awesome term
refers to a technique that is trying to
understand the direction of flows and
affect the colored regions according to
it in a way that is both visually and
temporally coherent visually coherent
means that it looks as close to
plausible as we can make it and
temporally coherent means that we are
not looking only at one frame but a
sequence of frames and the movement
through these neighboring frames has to
be smooth and consistent these animation
sequences were created from eight to
nine colorized frames and whatever you
see happening in between filled in by
the arrow
and again we are talking about the
artistic style here not the simulation
itself a fine handcrafted work in the
world dominated by advanced learning
algorithms this paper is a bit like a
beautiful handmade automatic timepiece
in the era of quartz watches if you
enjoyed this episode make sure to leave
a like on the video and don't forget to
subscribe to get a glimpse of the future
on the channel twice a week thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time
[Music]